c'est au Moyen-Âge que le village de
Château Renault naît protégé par la
forteresse qui surplombe la
vallée le long desberges des deux
rivières qui traversent la cité se
développent les activités du textile et
de la Tanerie d'artisanal jusqu'au 18e
siècle elles passeront au 19e siècle au
stade industriel la ville s'en trouve
transformée nous rencontrons willly
mzarek chargé du patrimoine il est notre
guide
au 19e siècle à partir de 1830 on a une
spécialisation du aussi aux guerres
révolutionnaire et au guerre de l'Empire
on a une spécialisation en cuir à
semelle donc un cuir gros un cuir épais
fait à partir de vaches de bœuf donc un
changement et donc ce type de cuir à
semelle ça va être le produit phare qui
va être travaillé jusque dans les années
1950- 1960 ici dans ce qui va être
dénommé la cité du cuir la la brique
prend le pas sur la pierre et la chaud
les taneries pour être fonctionnelles
sont bâtis avec une architecture
spécifique il faut imaginer toute la
ville de Château Renaud avec ce style
architectural de bâtiment où on avait au
bord des rivières des accès sur l'eau
pour les tenurs qui avaient besoin de
l'eau pour leur travail et puis des
bâtiments vous voyez ici un séchoir le
dernier à être conservé dans la ville
pour faire sécher les cuirs un 19e
siècle château Renault comptera jusqu'à
16 tanneries la ville grossit 4500
habitants y vivent la plupart ouvriers
travaillant pour le cuire les ttineurs
vivaient et travaillaient dans un
secteur très rapproché et on a cette vie
de ttinnerie d'activités de bruit
d'odeur qui se mêlaient au sein de la
même de la même ambiance et du même
quartier industriel et
[Musique]
industrieux
au 19e siècle la main d'œuvre qualifiée
est très recherchée pour retenir les
ouvriers le paternalisme patronal se
développe et crée des avantages sociaux
une des premières sociétés de secours
mutuel en France sera créée ici en
1824 la ville vivait de la Tanerie
c'était une mono-industrie on avait
cette cohabitation aussi bien pendant le
travail
en dehors du travail oou des jardins
ouvriers et les cabarets les cafés
sous-entendus étai faisaient partie de
cet environnement immédiat ainsi que les
commerces coopératifs ouvriers
solidaires les patron tanneurs vivaient
sur les lieux certains vivaient ailleurs
certains à tour vivaient à tour et
avaient leur usine à Château Renault
d'autres avaient leur maison à Château
Renault et leur usine à proximité on
avait cette cohabitation cette mixité
entre les patrons les taneurs au 20e
siècle l'industrie de la semelle cuire s
fond fondre dans les années 3050 le
caoutchou le plastique les simil cuirs
envahissent le marché puis dans les
années 70 c'est l'importation à bas prix
du cuir d'Amérique du Sud dans cette
période 15 usines ferment puis
disparaissent détruites par le
feu en 1985 la dernière tainerie cessse
son activité la ville alors décide de
réhabiliter ce patrimoine
industriel on a deux quartiers
environnants de ces espaces de Tanerie
qui sont en pleine voie d'évolution avec
des cabinets d'architectes qui
travaillent d'urbanisme de paysagers qui
travaillent à la réhabilitation de ces
ensemble et à l'unification de ces
ensembles pour que le citoyen se
réapproprie l'espace ces anciennes
usines elles sont parfois détruites
elles sont parfois réhabilités ici un
bon exemple de réhabilitation avec une
ancienne tannerie réhabilitée en siège
social pour la communauté de commune et
la place nouvellement réhabilité pour
accueillir une nouvelle place de marché
la place des droits de l'homme où
autrefois s'élevaient plusieurs fauses
de
teaineries Château Renault a fait le
choix de sauvegarder son identité et sa
mémoire industrielle faisant des
quartiers d'étaneries un nouveau paysage
chargé
d'histoire